to the last over year and a half but in
particularly for the last year and a
half I've been like a lot of people
sitting on my couch watching television
and watching seemingly one sickening
incident after another that never seems
to stop literally unarmed people being
shot and killed you know you talk to
black folks they'll be saying I hate
this [ __ ] didn't start a year and a half
ago all right but now with actually
iPhones capturing this footage and
seeing it that seems pretty undeniable
to us layman so I'm sitting there well
maybe it's getting so bad that things
can change and then actually the rise up
October people got in touch with me and
they basically said well are you going
to be part of the change are you going
to just keep sitting on your couch
lamenting the situation at some point
you have to take aside if you you know
this must stop
they must stop killing these people and
there is this institutional racism that
is that is just bred in law enforcement
that's happened in the last 30 years and
it needs to stop and to be silent is to
acquiesce to it people are talking about
boycotting they're pissed now now the
discussion hasn't become about the movie
it becomes about you personally right
and the discussions not about what we
were discussing it's not about the
subject yeah it's about this celebrity
all right came out and open his big
mouth and when they call you are you
like oh [ __ ] I really [ __ ] up maybe I
just should have kept quiet all the buzz
away it was a weird you know it was a
weird dichotomy because look I had every
right to say what I said and I was being
completely misrepresented by you know
the Union mouthpiece is like Patrick
Lynch
they weren't even crucifying me for what
I said they were crucifying me for
implications I didn't I didn't say and I
didn't mean I didn't say that I'm a cop
hater or I despise cops or all cops or
murderers I mean should be it you can in
this society still understand there
needs to be a police force and they do
good work and you can still criticize
police brutality